your single moms right do you feel like
it's fair to accept accept monogamy
um or to expect monogamy from someone
when you've given someone else a child
so they're not getting the youth and
like the Purity that they want I don't
remember I don't agree with your beliefs
so okay I'm gonna say no I would say
don't pick me in the first place yeah
yeah I didn't realize you were kids too
yeah I have one child oh is it do you me
yeah okay
um yeah no okay I think it depends on
the guy doesn't it like because if he's
like
actually too fair if you said no then
fine but I think the higher value a man
is the more likely a woman is going to
accept that but if he's like just so
average but if you're gonna accept it
you're gonna accept that anyway not
because you've got kids not because
that's what that's why I say no I think
if a woman's gonna accept that she's
going to accept that but I think most
women do accept it
I'm saying like how do most
relationships start nowadays
situationships side chicks
um like if you're in a situationship
like that's how most relationships start
is like talking okay and so I'm saying
like like most girls start that's what
you're starting as I won't say me
talking to someone automatically makes
me as such I would think okay okay would
you say the majority of the time sex
comes first to relationships which are
six definitely okay so when when you're
having sex with someone you're not
exclusive what are a side chick I'm
having sex with someone that I'm seeing
yeah but I'm saying like he's also
sleeping with other people so exactly so
I agree with you on that that I think
you'll be very delusional to meet a guy
today and the first time you've slept
with him you think you're the only
person he's sleeping with at that moment
because you're just you've just come
into the picture I don't know if I like
you so he as in he's thinking that I
don't know if I like you I'm just seeing
where this goes and obviously you've
allowed me to enter your sexual
experience so I'm also going to
experience this while I'm here but the
sex is not gonna determine if I'm gonna
be with you that's why I'm that's why
you should be selective for YouTube and
and when you allow him to access yeah
but like the point is you still start
off as a side chick
is what there's many chicks
for you to be aside you're going to have
a main right you have a main chick and
then you understand and that's what you
can only be that you can never be the
main one of his side chicks is the main
chick at one point in time
she might not have the title right but
he has a favorite he has a number one
draft pick
you know what though I think I think in
regards to the question about
to monogamy when you've had a child
I would say
universally if a woman hasn't helped me
attain my high value status then she
can't expect monogamy from me um
she hasn't contributed to me I'm not I
don't if you have because you have to
remember and I always say this like
women are born of value whilst men have
to create their value if I've had to
work hard and strive and do what I need
to do to attain a certain wealth you're
buying into that lifestyle having done
nothing so the only thing you can give
to me is is probably kids and whatnot
and again if I want to give you monogamy
I can but you can't expect it from me
because you haven't done anything to to
Warrant the lifestyle but when when
you're 20 and or 21 or whatever and you
start building would you want to get
into a serious relationship really a lot
of men and I said this on the show as
well it's context um for guys who were
in the late 20s building their
Foundation to or set their foundations
they want someone to contribute to their
lifestyle
women that you're looking for a guy
who's already made obviously if you're
going for a guy who's 21 22 23 you
should expect a young boy's mentality
yeah I have a question for you go on
would you keep that same mindset for a
woman who hasn't helped you contribute
haven't helped contribute to your mic oh
sorry do you have the same mindset for a
lady who hasn't helped to contribute to
get you to where the level you're at now
um but she doesn't have a child
yeah you have the same mindset yeah yeah
he said that in general yeah because
pearly was asking about yeah
University but I mean the point the
point is that men like are compromising
on their mating strategy but not getting
their mating strategy fulfilled in
return and what is that so they're
they're amazing strategies they don't
want to pass on resources to another
man's kid like that's why that's why
they're repulsed by hoes that's why
they're they're repulsed by like other
people's children
it's like a natural so so women want to
lock down and get commitment from the
highest value guy they can we're men
they want Purity and youth and they want
to know that the kids are theirs so they
get neither and we get what we want so
are you in a relationship
and anybody that you get with from now
are you going to be faithful I haven't
I'm close I get high value status in it
so I'm still in the very I'm still very
much in my building but yeah yeah I met
someone now and I'm able to build to
attain that level then you deserve it
exclusively can I ask you a question
okay the going was intense but let's say
let's let's say you were someone who was
willing to date someone who had a child
and you're in your growing your building
status and she was happy and willing to
build with you
would you be faithful to her
so I've accepted one for kids yeah
obviously in a normal circus and I said
that would happen anyway but if it did
and you know what let me just say I
think never say never type thing yeah I
think what what plays into my idea with
that is again it's the fact I'm Nigerian
and I know that would be even better you
know it's so funny you say that yeah but
in in Nigeria Nigerian men in Nigeria
accept girls with kids more than here my
parents are on smoke okay I know for a
fact oh does it come from like a
cultural thing so what I've watched my
own experience most mothers wouldn't
want yeah
from my experience as a single mother
right I get more smoke here than I get
in Nigeria and I think and I think a big
part of that a big part of that is
because back back in Nigeria uh a man
who
who took on another woman's child that
wasn't his he gets a lot of honor and
respect for that yeah yeah yeah probably
like back in the day it used to happen
but because it's almost like oh wow he's
the man who not only is he supplying for
his own kids but for someone else's
there came a lot of respect for that so
I think it was more regarded in high
regard but it's not regarded like that
today like in Nigeria you can say that
I'll be like oh I've got kids they only
think daily joke that they make an idea
is like you know you London kids like
London girls like to have kids quickly
that is it but they don't they don't say
like oh you're less of a woman but they
even find women with kids a lot more
serious
very much say a lot of the
responsibility if the if the family
doesn't go well a lot of responsibility
falls on the woman like it's the woman's
fault if anything goes wrong what if the
marriage doesn't work
it's one of the reasons she's scared
that anything would happen in the
marriage obviously everything is good
but if it was she would say the problem
falls on a woman that's very still very
much so the case like obviously modern
day women now you know so mad I I agree
with you I I as much as is is
um a hard pill to swallow
majority of the marriages that don't
last is because of the woman not like
she was the problem but she just wasn't
willing to show the blame no she was
just not willing to continue because
like if if I was to sit here and start
dissecting my marriage you'd be like but
you could have worked it through do you
know what I mean like yeah yeah but and
this is why I say that if someone if you
if you one of the issues or the mistakes
I made I didn't date a bad boy I'm not
interested in Bad Boys I was it wasn't a
thing for me I did I dated the quite I
was married to a quiet guy but what I
didn't pay attention to and that was
lack of knowledge is attributes
mannerisms how you'll raise Family
Values all of that those were my
problems it wasn't oh he was cheating or
um you know he he was we just did it I
was just fed up it was that our values
didn't work together so that's why it's
my fault because you could turn around
and say that why didn't you pick up
those things but I wasn't wise enough to
pick up on those things can I can I ask
did you leave sorry yeah did you left
sorry yeah okay first yeah do you ever
get back with him no and you know we're
so mad yet you remember the last time we
came you said I don't uh you don't know
so in a figure of speech right when the
last time we came he said that um part
of a marriage um as a woman you're meant
to for your kids you're meant to stay in
a marriage but I remember I said it I
said the main reason why I left was
because of my kids because when you look
at my kids now they're a lot calmer the
teachers don't complain about them when
I was the teachers used to complain a
lot about my children's Behavior just
them being unsettled just being but as
soon as I facilitated structure they're
fine is that because you and your your
husband was showing the troubles in your
relationship to you this was even after
we broke up and he had access to the
kids okay as soon as that access was no
longer there they were a lot more
settled I but don't get me wrong I I am
so scared raising my boys because I'm a
woman
you know what I mean so like even little
things like when my son comes upstairs
and he's crying even though I want to
hug him because I don't want to make the
mistakes I believe some parents have
made on their sons I have to be Stern
you know I mean and I I get scared that
am I confusing this boy that he need a
woman is meant to be aggressive
I respect that because that's a
difficult situation yeah do you get what
I'm saying it's like how do you teach
him because a lot of women don't even
take that into account a lot of women
just they do the the motherly thing
which is just to like Cottage yeah
because when I have a second question
would you take him back if there was no
other man on the planet no I won't be on
my own I've started to even though I
don't like it and I'm praying to God it
doesn't happen but I'm starting to
have that 10 that you may be on your own
for a long time
um do you think you'll have 2.5 million
saved up to retire
I think being same time you're 60. yes
if that's what I wanted I will have what
I want okay yeah I I one thing about me
and anyone will tell you I work hard I'm
I am a grinder well women like like
because the thing is
you're probably in a small percentage of
women that make that amount of money but
a lot of women will be homeless in that
position yeah and I don't think they're
really educated about that because I
mean I know there's like government
benefits here but you don't know
tomorrow they could take them away yeah
yeah and be rely on that
can I ask you a question to the ladies
as many of you know is just banned
band talk
instead of sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible